hello hey MA I sang I'm just taking a
walk
oh yes it's a little under 100 nano
later this week's gonna be 107 so I
figure I better get my walks in you
might melt mom I'm not gonna do it when
it's 170 I mean really you're only you'd
either have to do it after it we're dark
oh yeah that's dangerous too cuz they
have a lot of snakes out there or really
early in the morning like usually well
that snakes I have to eat some right
away so and that snakes too mom yeah
yeah well not what is that insect that I
found in the house they sprayed for it
once for me something I cannot er
tarantula but having the desert it can
to a lot of people it's poisonous so I
found I can tell you what I think
horrible in the house well you're gonna
end up on one of those special shows
where people get us like for kind of
four seniors that get attacked by snakes
you know or something yeah well look at
least if you go into the belly of a warm
snake at least you got a nice place to
be you know yeah it could be pretty much
of a monster but they do exist I know
you've seen some big ones sometimes on
your walk haven't you remember back in
the day yeah I think you it was during
the time that you stayed there first
short time when we lived on enough air
wave grows oh yeah gargantuan snake that
was the only time I've ever seen one
method so what do you think that's gonna
not kill Roseanne but it won't help her
huh well I just I don't know what did
you think whenever you heard about it I
just bagged her well I wanted your
opinion and then when I got your opinion
I thought well maybe that will him her
in as just being a comedian of
controversy
controversial I guess yeah and you know
when really I mean witness her old shows
she's a good all-around comedian yeah
yeah I agree I think it kind of like it
kind of I don't know part of me I would
love to have gone on a tour with her you
like I said I would have loved her going
on a tour with her honestly if I'm
really honest with myself
ya know I know one of those probably
tiny things yeah but a trip didn't say
when they you know when he initially
pitched it I assume he pitched it to her
but I don't even know there yeah
well I think you know I think um you
know I think she probably thinks that
people don't like her more than is the
reality I think I think a lot of people
still really do like her but also I
think her and dice have a real
comfortable connection they've been
friends for a long time she like Kate
she like jumped up on stage at one of
his shows a couple of months ago and
yeah and had like a comfortable response
and they used to do shows together in
Vegas you know so I think some of them
might just be a comfort thing to like if
I'm gonna go tour with somebody who
would it be
but I think it's a good move for him he
like at at you know I think that I I
feel like a lot more people would come
out to see her these days but right who
might not come out to see him I know
what he looks like but I'm not I know
what I read said he'd been banned from
something I don't know what it was
television oh yeah but I don't really
know anything bad it said he still does
stand up on his own yeah well I see him
at the comedy store sometimes so yeah is
he any good yeah I mean I think he's a
you know desired taste I mean he's still
you know he's a comedian he's not really
he's never been really in for like nice
to me whenever I've seen him so I may
have a I may have sometimes an unfair
impression of like what I how I look at
his comedy but to me some of its it's
not really my favorite like if somebody
asked me who's one of your favorites I
wouldn't you know I wouldn't not even I
wouldn't even think of him right so I
guess they hooked up because of way
you say long-term friendships and also
because they can both be controversial
well he is all the time I go yeah now it
could be a huge tour though a lot of
people were like you know what I'm gonna
go out and see ya see just see him you
know just see him say whatever you know
people yeah the last like hurrah for
people saying whatever they want to say
get out I guess she's not dead unless no
I don't think she is either that's I
think she thinks she is more than she is
well maybe when it's all done you still
get a chance but they're doing something
more benign even if you do the little a
little family in the van yeah yeah I
talked to her manager a couple times I'm
still trying to figure it out so but uh
but yeah then yeah that's a good point
all right mom portrait are you doing a
podcast yeah I'm actually but just about
the tape right now so yeah well thank
you for calling yeah thanks for
answering MA and hope your walk goes
well huh
love you all right let me - bye okay bye
well do you know what I was thinking was
that tits are heart like a hard like a
chest is just like a man's chest it's
kind of like hard tits really when you
think about that like petrified almost
it's like if you had like if somebody
buried a couple of you know beautiful
just milky front knuckles out in the
yard and they got and they got real hard
overtime and you dug them back up they'd
be almost like a man's chest
so I don't even know what that means man
[Music]
broke down out of truck stop she looked
about as wild as the story she told said
she was a Christian saving souls in
Savannah and the Senate
[Applause]
[Music]
lord I hope I don't die in Alabama that
heat that's was look this is the time of
year it is summertime they call it for
here now somewhere else somebody's
dealing with winter somebody and maybe
Moscow or somewhere somebody's throwing
a damn uh not a crystal ball but a
snowball at somebody
imagine that yeah
if you imagined it then you just did and
if you didn't then you just didn't it's
up to you but yeah this is summer and
summer's here boy and summer is man
he's a dirty boy hidden he I mean he is
a dirty boy he's hot and he just is just
relentless he is relentless and that is
summer that's like somebody if you give
uh you know some time he'd catch a boy
in the neighborhood or something got a
little bit of alt ISM you know that ISM
and they say it and if you give him a
little hammer you know they had a boy in
our area that's born in wild Jacob and
he was always eating you know he'd run
around and pick berries and everything
in the summer and you know when the
berry bushes really started to flourish
you catch him out there with the blue
you know the black died on his hands
picking berries and eating them that's
the problem his mom gave him this little
hat and he's supposed to put the berries
in there but he woulda just to eat him
immediately and he get home and he did
have you know 120 berries in his stomach
but uh at one time his uncle I'll
remember pass through town or something
gave him a little hammer
and I mean I swear to God we thought we
had a damn woodpecker in the
neighborhood for probably four years but
um but while Jacob would just get off in
the woods and he find him a little tree
or something or a little you know area
of hardness maybe a fence board or a
piece of stone or granite and he would
just hit it with that hammer while Jacob
be up there would just bury stains all
over his face just just just for hours
and hours just [ __ ] probably sending
Morse code to who know I mean I'm sure
over in you know and chair Noble or
somewhere rusher you know who knows
outerspace they're thinking of it some
wild unique Morse code is coming in you
know there's so there's some you know
stenographer at NASA that's writing it
all down but meanwhile that's just
freaking barry jacob old blackberry
jacob but his little hammer just beating
something we thought we had you know
exotic birds but that's how relentless
summer is man it's like given a hammer
to uh like giving a hammer to a young
fellow with autism and he's out there
doesn't just chiseling away I mean Jacob
will [ __ ] he chiseled a damn uh Mount
Rushmore into the side of a school
building or so I mean I'm he just pissed
everybody off you know you come out of
um you know this is you'd come out of
the out of school or out of your house
and he would have chiseled a damn Deion
Sanders into the side of a a a Honda I
go what the [ __ ] man I mean he just had
a real unique style to him
but that's the thing you know and that's
how relentless he just I mean he was
banks he didn't have nothing on this
fella bank seeing [ __ ]
banks he's just some sneaky dude in the
middle of the night with a marker but
I'm just saying while Jacob was out
there all day with a freaking wanted him
a little baby hammers son just
rearranging the world uh but that's how
summer is man it is relentless beating
it is and it's that time you almost want
to buy your mother a damn ice hat you
know it's almost like you want to drown
somebody but don't fully drown them just
hold them under cold water for a you
know about 40 seconds just to let them
catch a little bit of relief from the
heat
it's summertime in the year 2019 and it
is June 24 and thank you for joining us
also support for this past weekend comes
from manscaped who is number one in
men's below-the-belt grooming and look
I'll tell you this I shaved about
probably maybe if maybe about a fortieth
of a pound of hair off of my body
yesterday so I gave my whole body a damn
a nice fade and you sometimes you have
so much body hair you can't even really
you try to hug somebody and they bounce
right off of you I mean jeepers
manscaped offers precision-engineered
tools for your family jewels
no more chipping at your whacker you
feel me I've remember one time this is
probably maybe maybe a year ago and I
was using scissors man and I got it
makes me feel crippled in my heart to
even talk about this but I was using
scissors to clip hair that was all and
growing on my scrotum
and and my scrotums they uh they don't
want scissors bond and it's funny if you
put a pair of scissors in new your
scrotum and your nuts on this will climb
up inside of your body because inside of
your ball bag there's actual balls in
there they're different entities but
what I'm saying is this manscaped has
redesigned the electric trimmer their
lawnmower 2.0 has proprietary skin-safe
technology so this trimmer won't Nick or
snag your nuts
shoutout to premature Nick our producer
manscaping accidents are finally a thing
of the past you know your grandfather
used to chip his nuts all the time he
was probably out there like dang
what's-his-name
like like wile Jacob with that little
hammer trying to hammer the hair off the
off of his nut sock and don't use the
same trimmer on your face as you're
using on your balls that's nasty bucko
manscaped also has the crop preserver an
anti chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer you already put deodorant on
your armpits why are you not putting
deodorant on the smelliest part of your
body what do you talk do my Wang smells
Joya Bulai think get 20% off free
shipping with the code Theo
at manscaped com always use the right
tools for the right job and I will say
manscaped has created that culinary set
to help you fine-tune the hair around
your rod and tribe your balls will thank
you get 20% off free shipping and a free
travel bag with the code th EO at
manscape com
that's 20% off with free shipping and a
travel bag at manscaped calm and use
code Theo I want to let you know today's
episode is brought to you by skill share
skills share is the online learning
community for creators it has more than
25,000 classes and design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career take classes in social media
Marketing mobile photography creative
writing even illustration whether you're
looking to discover a new passion start
a side hustle or gain that professional
skill set that you've never had you want
to do this or do that you can do it
Skillshare is there to keep you learning
thriving and reaching those new goals
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for my listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right skills share skills share is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo von again go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo von to start your two months
now that Skillshare dot-com slash Theo
von oh yeah it's summertime thank you
guys for good to see you good to hear
you what's up man just kind of relaxing
this weekend I went to a chiropractor
and I don't know if you ever been to a
chiropractor but this shady is the
shadiest thing it's basically like going
to the Mafia for your body it's like
taking your body to like a mafia person
because they got you in a headlock they
pinning you to the ground they are
asking you questions about you you know
it's Jesus by the end I'm like I you
know I'm just telling them where the
treasures buried even if I didn't do
[ __ ] I'm just making stuff up you know
it's in US it's in a safety deposit box
it's in a locker at the Greyhound
station because they put that dude this
lady and she might have been into some
wild stuff she might have been into some
real Dark Arts I think because I had you
know I felt like she had a little bit of
you ever hug somebody and they kind of
they feel like they might have been
doing cocaine a little bit
like that so you know but whatever you
know we didn't blood test each other I
was just there so I don't really know
anything but but um but yeah well I went
in there and and next thing you know
she's got me on the table she's got me
in a figure four figure five she had me
in all kinds of [ __ ]
she had my heart you know she had she
tied both my arms into a knot under
inside of her mouth with her tongue I'm
like what is this is I mean she was
doing unique stuff and this was all
non-sexual just this whole deal cause me
probably about a hundred 100 and maybe
twenty dollars 160 or twenty dollars I
don't know but dude they get in there
they get they put the bone right in your
zone this lady had me she had my
orifices just just nervous boy I mean my
whole body felt like a dang behold I be
honest with you my whole body felt like
a behold and I say behold you know some
people don't want to hear that they you
know they some people say butthole and I
don't say that because I'm not that I
don't say that kind of stuff if I can
help it but yeah this lady had that you
know she got my whole body was feeling
nervous like a behold boy because people
don't want to talk about that backdoor
deal that behold a lot and that thing I
mean it'll barely kind of accept a
marble the thing is uh cautious I think
is a good word to describe it it's like
you know you know it's like got a really
small small welcome mat if it has one at
all and that behold it's really it's a
temperamental deal but yeah this lady
had my whole body feeling like that like
my whole body was just covered up with
just you know
that honest you know that honest that
behold so it wasn't it was a unique
experience but you go in there she's got
you in this she's got you in that she's
got you
she had my arms behind my back she was
[ __ ] asking me questions
you know she threat I was like why I
know it was gone she threatened me she
told me I got a C when I was in you know
that I cheated in high school she was
saying a lot of things that were I
thought egregious that had nothing to do
with skeletal or muscular then they put
you on this table and they put this long
cable to your neck and she goes over by
the door and Yanks that thing I mean it
just just from and suddenly I [ __ ]
dude I'm I didn't know what what's going
on I mean I just felt kind of just
tightened up you know I felt like my
pants just were you know we're gonna fit
better I felt just like my dick and my
just you know I just felt like my I just
felt like my just like my dick had just
won a medal or something just
straightened everything up in my body
immediately you know I felt like I just
won third place in a damn spine contest
you know what the at the spine center of
it air off the interstate but anyway I'm
kind of rambling we had last week we had
a question that you know we had a caller
that called in we're talking about
relationships and things like that and
just things that I find her and a lot of
people's worlds right now and in my
world for sure you know I think a lot
about relationships and you know if I
want it if I can handle it
you notice really have a tough time and
commitment man I just have a really
there's just something inside of me that
is very scared of it even just you know
if I think about like getting like a
wedding or something that scares me if I
think about you know but also
what scares me also is being alone and
not having someone that scares me really
in a different way that scares me more
cerebral II like it you know I can think
about well I might not have children or
grandchildren and you got to have
grandchildren but those dudes they seem
like [ __ ] great you know really good
little buckaroos children who knows what
will happen
these em efforts but grandchildren
brought a [ __ ] doing everything you
could give them as many smoothies as you
want you know give him a couple
lollipops hit him with that suppository
broth they sick grandchildren you could
do anything with the grandchildren put
them outside put them on a swing give
them another smoothie utter tired
they're crying get that smoothie little
Bryce or whatever your name is little D
addre what you want another couple of
Necco wafers you know grandpa got you I
might be that undercover grandpa just
kind of roll up on children in the mall
non-sexual you know just roll up on
children at the mall or at the and hit
them with a couple of you know a cut of
a KitKat break them off one you know one
of those you know 25% of a KitKat boy or
hit him with a damn you know a half a
handful of payday split a payday candy
bar with him and my mother used to love
eating paydays boys used to crack open a
couple cans of beer and she put that
lawn chair out and the windows open and
she would lay out in indoor she would
lay out on the thing indoors but and you
know and she would have that payday
candy and that's more than payday candy
bars used to be an adult
he's been adult candy but but yeah I was
talking about last week about just
parenting and co-parenting and what do
people think about that kind of stuff
and we had a caller that called in this
was an excerpt from his call right here
I'm 31
and I'm kind of trying to figure out you
know do I want a child or not you know I
think my big problem is I don't have a
phobia
having a child with the wrong lady no
because whether you like to believe it
or not you're attached to that person
for at least 18 years you know the girl
so I kind of want to make sure it's
right you know before I have before I
bring a child into this world and and
you guys hit some responses as always
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three you guys had some
nice responses that are here's one that
came in right here hey Co this is Sarah
from Chicago hey Sarah and I'm actually
wearing the Chicago Cubs flight at duh
baby and I love Chicago man it's just
really it's a city that really I feel
like has still has a good bit of a ortus
you know it's got a lot of business but
it's got a lot of heart you got people
coming up there that are you know
they're looking to do business but
they're also just looking to enjoy you
know seeing other people and meeting
other people and it's a good place to
still get a business card from somebody
and put it in your pocket and actually
use it let's hear more and that lady who
gave her husband ends up in the back of
her dad's car for the first time oh yeah
Sarah Sarah with that magical touch you
got that you put that David Copperfield
on your husband huh and next thing you
know you're making is uh you're making
his uh blue balls disappear you have
that magical touch touching your man
well your dad's driving that's literally
that's a ballsy move let's hear more I
just heard your comment about
co-parenting and I know some people who
are co-parenting now or are kind of just
taking the parenting life as if it's
just ours easy that works out it works
out as a dozen that doesn't you know and
that's not how the child sees it I've
seen I work with kids actually with
speech therapist and I work with
children and I deal with those kids
every day where co-parenting just isn't
working out and it really isn't working
out for the child make sure you have a
sure
foundation in that relationship
otherwise it is just it can be
detrimental for you yes but incredibly
detrimental for that child especially
because when we're baby's important to
this world the only thing we know is our
parents that's that's where we find out
what love is and if we don't see it from
the co-parenting then do we really know
what kind of love we deserve or what
kind of love we should get onward field
Gang Gang Gang Gang sir appreciate that
you know that's a good that's a really
interesting thought yeah because if
you're just Co parents and you dig the
children now you could still show the
child some love the children will feel
love from a male parent and a female
parent or but I mean or it could be you
know same-sex parents but I think I I
mean I feel like you you're gonna get
more of a full batch if you have that
male/female I mean that's you know it's
been the current it's been the recipe
it's been mother nature's recipe to have
the male-female but yeah it's like
you'll get that the kid will still get
the love from a parent a male parent and
a female parent but they won't get they
won't maybe see the example of love so
they might not see the parents love each
other they may not see there's like an
element that they could really miss so
you hadn't really thought about that
exactly that if yeah if you live on one
street and your kid lives yeah if you
live on one street with your kid and the
dad lives across the street or down the
way and you guys are just kind of you
know back and forth it may feel kind of
dis this you know that it might not be
continuous parenting it may kind of
start and stop here and there and then
also kids might start to learn well love
is just love is just you know you get
love from one person from a mom or from
a dad and it's not a also something you
see
so if they don't see the love between
the parents so then the kid my the kid
could feel like that like that that love
isn't or isn't something that's even in
the world you know because I've never
seen an example of it it's just I get
love from my mom here I get love from my
dad here but I don't see an example of
love between two people that are you
know like in a marriage or two people
like a man and a woman that love each
other then the kid might grow up and not
really feel an attraction anybody they
might be fully asexual they may sexers
so that's interesting you know I
appreciate you sharing that thanks for
calling in Sarah and look once again
thanks for you know sharing that story
two episodes ago about dropping that HJ
on your husband back in a day well your
dad was driving y'all around manners I
mean that that episode really I think
took us all to a beautiful place in time
that that you can only exist in as a
child you know and as a first-time when
you get that first touch let's let's
take another call that came in here
here we go hey Co this is Vivian from
Los Angeles hey Vivian from LA thank you
for calling in onward I was listening to
last week's episode and I thought I'd
share a story
my mom and dad were really young when
they had me my mom was 19 and my oh yeah
that's beautiful my dad was couple years
older oh yeah so he trying to be wild
like that with the young ladies I've
done it I feel it homework and they
never got married for some time I was
really young and they lived apart from
each other and you know talked me back
and forth between them but once I
actually got into elementary school they
decided to move in together and become
roommates in Chicago nothing remains
Hertz or anything like that they just
wanted you know to co-parent together in
the same household and honestly it was
my favorite time of my childhood so yeah
if any single parent
are considering co-parenting in the same
household I could say from my experience
it was really really good for me and
actually I just kind of miss it like
yeah JJ thank you for calling in let me
look up really quick the definition of
co-parenting just so I'm operating on it
clean
co-parenting share the duties of
parenting especially of a separated or
unmarried couple so basically it is
people co-parenting sometimes called
joint parenting or shared parenting is
the experience of raising children as a
single parent
when separation or divorce occurs
however placing the sole focus on your
children can be a great way of helping
to make co-parenting a positive
experience so it's where both where the
parents are single but they're both
raising the child so that could be in a
couple of ways where you know you guys
are you know just you guys are divorced
it could be that you guys are like this
situation roommates
so obviously it's it there is something
special that happens when as a child
then from your perception when when both
your parents are in the same place and I
and you know what I could really imagine
that it's like because with parents you
can play off or you can play one off of
the other it's fun to see them interact
you know they're like this when you're a
kid your parents are like this weird
comedy duo sometimes it's just cruising
around the house just trying to take
away your privileges so it's really
interesting to have I guess to get to
see them at the same time interact with
each other it could be kind of lonesome
if you just go to your dad's house and
he's just being you know kind of sad or
something or looking up escorts and are
just being like a nice guy or you go to
your mom's house and she's just kind of
being sad or mind he's crazy you know
high-powered sexual toys you know these
real you know these crotch you know damn
John Deere is making things for women's
crotches now and it
is just good god I mean they got some
things that run on gas-powered you got a
you know you got a ding you know you got
a float the choke a little bit before
you can even get that thing to start up
and so that's really I don't know what
kind of I don't know what's going on so
yeah I think seeing those parents get
getting to see your parents kind of give
each other a wet willy or tickle each
other or to you know or try on scarves
or different things like that there's
gonna be something special there having
that moment where your paint you know
maybe playing hide-and-go-seek and both
your parents are there to play with you
know there is something about having
them in the same house so now maybe if
your parents like you said your parents
just happen to live together they
weren't married but they lived in the
same house so maybe co-parenting is more
effective if the parents are living in
the same home even if they're not
married but they're there together at
the same time which I could imagine
because from what I hear there's a lot
of like something that happens with like
a nesting you know where it feels like
you're in a nest and a safe place where
you can grow you know your mom is there
to nurture you your father is there to
take care of and provide and it feels
probably very natural to us because a
lot of species do it you know you see
this show they got a thing called ah
what is it penguin
I don't know Polar Express or something
maybe it's like about a bunch of
penguins it's on the nature show they
have a bunch of penguins and these
mother dude these guys they're penguins
I don't know if you know penguins are
they're basically they're kind of they
act like kind of like little [ __ ] I
mean they don't you know they kind of
short with people you know they always
like just you know they don't even
really you know they just sitting over
there giving you that uh who's that guy
that slumber jay arm what's your boy he
was I could barely point at the oil John
McCain you know he got that low hitter
you know he just got that I mean it's
very very you know he got that half-mast
baby you know and he you know
they that's how they raised their arm a
little penguins they don't do much the
guys all kind of huddle around and then
the women they get pissed and they jump
off of a mountain and go get a belly of
fish and then they come back one of them
vomits into the child and then the other
one goes out but I think as the child to
see your parents just doing that shift
that you know that teamwork that tandem
you realize I bet you learn a lot about
you know what it takes as a team as a
tandem to make it work you know my
parents I remember my dad like to sleep
in his car at the park and he would
sometimes drink too much and he would
just stay outside and just sleep in his
car in front of the house and he used to
have a lot of cups of like different
Mardi Gras to balloons from the parade
and uh and he would just throw them out
of his car when he was driving like kind
of like he was his own little parade a
little bit I mean he was also 80 years
old at this point or said you know 78 or
something but but yeah sometimes he
would get a little bit of free champagne
because one of his friends worked at the
champagne distillery and he would drive
over old champagne and my dad I know
would sit out on the porch sometimes and
you know chug down a half a bottle of
old
pain and I would be out there and he
would let me smell his breath because I
like the way that the the champagne
smelled but then I think it's just fun
as a kid to have both of the parents
around it's something real I mean Jesus
I think just you know I mean there's
enough kids already that are raised by
single parents it's just a little hectic
it's not the same vibe but maybe that's
where we're headed and if we are headed
there as a species because we're such in
this meat generation and you know myself
and and I'll you know a lot of us are
they're not even by choice it's like you
know social media really puts us in our
own world in our own perceptions and you
know we have our own Facebook page we
have our own I G we have our own
snapchats we have our own whatever it is
tick tocks or whatever it's all our own
personal things that it you know we
start to look at our as our lives as our
world just as ourselves it's just it's
just me it's just me so if that's where
we're headed as people then may then
then co-parenting might be the only
viable possibility because if your
parents aren't gonna live together
they're not gonna stay married or they
don't want to be married then at least
if they can live together in an
environment where they can raise a child
so I don't know I'm thinking a lot about
that kind of stuff just today for some
reason
[ __ ] man I'm [ __ ] tired you ever sleep
a lot and you're tired you're like dang
dude what was I doing in my dream was
running a lot or something but thank you
for calling in you know maybe there'll
be a turn where people start to you know
really make good choices about
relationships and you see a lot more
kids getting raised in the nest and and
you see just you know you see more of
that vibe a little bit but yeah that
hockey puck kind of style of child
raised and I don't know you know I've
never done it but I don't know what it's
I don't know if it's super healthy I
don't know and
sometimes you don't know sometimes some
kids is just made out of you know fish
and snails and puppy-dog pails you know
or whatever you know cinnamon and spice
and nothing nice or whatever you got a
kid who's got [ __ ] you know made out
of 70 grams a damn nutmeg in his neck
and he's never gonna get it together so
some of that is just kind of God's plan
I'm gonna tell you that today's episode
if you're struggling with something is
brought to you by better help calm it's
professional and affordable counseling
get matched with the counselor who's
right for you you might like a different
I've had all kind of counselors help my
first counselor I had ever in Los
Angeles
I saw her about nine years later
homeless no joke
it was kind of this thicker kind of I
want to say maybe this kind of Jewish
lady but she had I think she had a
mental illness but she uh she was eating
yogurt homeless and I was like damn dude
I took advice from this lady for like
about nine about nine months he uh man
is hit or miss in the universe boy but
professional and affordable counseling
better help calm you can get matched up
with the counselor who's right for you
for communication modes text chat phone
and video start communicating in there
in under 24 hours you must be 18 or
older this is available worldwide it's
not intended for those actively
considering suicide so if you thinking
about taking your life don't bother them
with it that's your you know that's not
for your own consideration really and
talk to a media professional 9-1-1 or
talk to somebody in your home or
something do not take your life but this
is a better help calm it's available on
desktop mobile web Android and iOS apps
you can send messages 24/7 365 to a
therapist I was having a tough day and I
pulled over on the side of the road and
hit up my better help therapist our lana
was her name are lana and next thing you
know I had a 40 minute chat with her
face-to-face on FaceTime
so it's helpful if you need this
scheduled video in phone sessions sign
up at better help.com slash Theo th EO
today
that's better help calm slash Theo
financial aid is available you know I've
been thinking about just trying to be
more certain about the things that I
need in my life even if I'm wrong some
sometimes I stay in this middle ground
I'm just so uncertain and I never really
kind of make a lot of choices I just
stay in this in this uncomfortable space
you know I've been thinking about I need
to own what my choices are even if
they're wrong because part of me just
wants to not make any choices so then I
don't ever take any kind of real risks
sometimes but then I spend all the time
in my hedges battling both side you know
both this both choices both decisions
it's like do I do this or do I do that
but instead of deciding I'll just keep
asking myself that do I do this do I do
that do I did it for months
should I do this show do the options
aren't even gone are gone it was like
should I pick this cabbage or this
little grapefruit at the produce and not
this [ __ ] his name wilted him and bought
by there but I'm still wondering in my
head you know it's like my
indecisiveness is just it's it's
exhausting honestly it's like what do I
do here if I choose this am I gonna hurt
somebody's feelings if I choose that am
I gonna hurt my feelings and sometimes I
only want to make choices of myself it's
like am i mentally well enough to even
make any choices like you know am i do I
need to get in a better place before I
make choices for myself I think that
sometimes like man do I should I even
make a choice right now I don't even
know if I'm doing okay I don't know life
just if someone was tricky
but let's take a let's taking this other
call about our about co-parenting here
we go going on field Zach from Phoenix I
just had some
jack-jack from Phoenix my second
favorite football team right there the
Arizona Cardinals and also let them
Detroit Lions own word advice for that
guys asking if he's too old to be having
kids or whatever yeah I was 23 when I
met a woman thought she was pretty cool
start dating only catch was is that she
was three months pregnant with someone
else's kid of course oh yeah
if you hit no yeah you met a woman she's
already pregnant with somebody else's
kid that's like kind of like when you
you ever go you ever do an Easter egg
hunt and you go when you already you go
to the bush and the eggs gone just like
that
this thing didn't end up working out but
I raised that kid for about three years
and it told me that having kids was
worth it you know even if [ __ ] might not
go right you might be worried you might
be with the wrong person or whatever in
my case I was and you know all the all
the tough [ __ ] was worth it
and so I say go for a man before you get
too damn old gang game gam bruh well
thank you for the suggestion yeah you
know I think a lot I mean I keep having
sperm in my body because you know I'm
even though I'm still off pornography
I'm back off I think I got like another
30 days under my belt and that's changed
my life I got to talk about that more
next week I'm gonna do that but so
talking about this how you know
pornography and being off of it has
really started to adjust the ways I
think and feel but yeah I keep having
when I do touch myself I see you know I
have sperm inside of my body that kind
of rears its little beak you know what
comes out of here you know that self
spray kinda and what I'm telling you is
that I can still do it so I appreciate
it yeah I might do it at some point but
I don't think I'm gonna do it right now
but at some point I might have to get
out there and catch as I go you know
catch
case of the of the you know full sexual
reproduction and I'm glad it was a good
experience for you brother
you know it's brave that men over there
get on the front line that's like I mean
that's almost like a little bitty
Vietnam that's almost like a skeet at
Nam you know when you got to raise
somebody else's you know skeet for a
while isn't it crazy that you have them
built like a man even a [ __ ] idiot
right now has a millions of babies
running around in his body little you
know kind of nut buddies and that all
you got to do is tickle them enough
around his wiener I know I know and
they'll show up I mean if that doesn't
sound like like a new minions movie then
I don't know what does right let's take
another call here we got a lot of good
calls coming in thank you very much hey
Valerie from Olympia up there and I
think maybe Washington or Olympia the
country I'm not sure oh thank you very
much yep Washington thank you thank you
guys for coming
what about somebody called talking about
a friend that didn't show up I mean he
might have been stalking them and it
might be somebody that he met off the
internet oh yeah this was we had a guy
who called in last week about um you
know he was kind of losing his friend
and he wasn't sure if he should still be
friends with him or not
because he felt like he was doing all of
the work all word I'd have been stalking
him and it might be somebody that he met
off the end of that and he just keeps it
in the bushes hoping that for some
reason that guy would call him back but
if it is truly his friend from the
childhood and he really does know him I
have to disagree with you I really feel
like if a relationship is toxic you got
to think about your own mental health
and and your own happiness at some point
and you shouldn't have to work that hard
to make a friendship work I'm not saying
that he has to cut them off or refuse
his call if that guy calls them but I do
think it's important
you surround yourself with people that
value you and just kind of let that one
go if he doesn't want to call him back
and they don't call him anymore
seek out friends that are worth your
time but also if you stalking him that's
a serious issue yeah now I appreciate I
appreciate the call you know what that's
a really good point that's a good
thought like yeah maybe yeah like
sometimes yeah if the person if it's not
cutting it for you then yeah let them go
you know when I just heard you say that
Valerie made me think about in my own
life like yes sometimes I will just keep
riding relationships even though there's
like nothing there maybe you know like
sometimes I have friends I'll keep
talking them even though every time I
talk to him like what is it are we still
even front what's going on even or am I
just somebody that for some weird reason
has been talking to this person every
now and then you know I think I've
always had a at whoa I wonder if I'm
just like afraid to let friendships go
because what if I don't know just so
happy to have any connection at all that
man I can't let it I can't let it go and
it is true it's like at a certain point
we're not helping ourselves it's like
some relationships I'm like are these is
this relationship even helpful or good
for me in my life or is it just a burden
but then part of me thinks well if this
is a burden maybe this other person
really needs somebody an excessive care
you know someone who just doesn't give
up on them you know even you know or
doesn't you know keeps it alive no
matter what
and I'm not saying that that that's a
right way to do it or that there's any
winner in the scenario I think because I
think in some cases you can really
exhaust yourself I really exhaust myself
sometimes you know keeping friendships
alive and some people though somebody's
probably thinking the same thing about
me like man I'm so [ __ ] tired of
texting Theo or reaching out and never
getting a response you know I got a guy
a buddy who uh you know who sent me you
know he sent me a couple of nice gifts
and he's been so supportive and and I
literally just not had time to reach out
to him and I always feel bad it's like
but yeah at some point even then at some
point am I just hurting their feelings
on the other side of the coin by would
it be big on me to just say man look I
know I'm not putting when I need to into
this relationship or into this buddy
ship right here this little buddy battle
so let me just step off the battlefield
yeah it's interesting I think it's case
by case basis but I will sometimes I
will just keep trying to friendship
because I don't I'm just afraid to let
it end even though there's nothing else
there even though you know I don't want
to put my faith that a different friend
will come along and fill that space a
better opportunity and the truth is for
me the experience the proof of
experience in my life has been that if I
leave space for new things that new
things will come along
as hard as it is as hard as it is to be
like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna let this
go I'm gonna let this rope go and just
start to close my other I'm gonna let
the Rope go with one hand and I'm gonna
start to close this other hand and at
the moment that this one hand has fully
let go of the one rope I'm just gonna
have faith that there's gonna be a nut
another rope will have formed in this
other hand at the exact moment I need it
to so that won't just disappear off into
the ether just fall into the void and it
always does that's the crazy thing every
time I give like faith or opportunity a
chance I feel like it always shows up
even though it's so hard to do it that's
tricky man damn we are tricky rabbits
boy uh let me get this call that came in
as always a hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three I need to
go run or something I got to get my
blood going I'm feeling like my blood is
slow yeah what's up to you this is a
Parker I'm here in uh New Jersey and you
know I'm in high school and I same two
classes you know 50 years damn you're in
high school do what Grady win forty one
forty second grade you in 19th grade man
you sound about 50 dude you sure you're
in high school thank you for calling man
I appreciate you calling I got to do
summer school and it sucks you know my
parents don't like it they're all pissed
off and they're disappointed in me it
sucks but you know like I do this summer
school and I was just wondering if any
advice for moving on from it using all
what high schools and trying to get into
college and just see you know would a to
do from here busy now I'm trying to get
the disappointment away from my parents
yeah man you got to go out there and get
that hitter
okay little kitten you got to freaking
put your tongue in the milk and start
doing the work
yeah your parents are disappointed
probably because they've really given
you know they've given you so some
environment maybe where you can really
prosper
I mean Parker really honestly is not
usually a poor kids name so because if
you Parker you got it you know unless
you're valet now that we usually that's
more valet is more a you know a poor
guys name sometimes like you know
actually it sounds actually kind of rich
valet that sounds French
that's my boy valet that's Parker so
really that's the same name but what I'm
saying is Parker
usually if you met a Parker that dude
you know what I'm saying he definitely
had a couple extra pudding packs in his
in his satchel and so you got the
opportunity I mean he's going to summer
school I think you need to decide if you
like school or not I'll tell you this
going to college is for is fun that's
what it is it's fun you get to meet
people you get to have fun you you know
I think you should start to maybe apply
yourself and see what you could do man I
bet you could do a little bit of magic
now also you could take another route if
your parents got a little bit of coin
you could get that a little bit of a
loan maybe and go do some wild [ __ ] get
out there on the you know hit the road
and get that bone going boy and get out
there and do some boning do some sex out
there travel America or travel Europe
but school I think school is cool
because it's just it's an experience you
can't really go back to school later on
in life that much and have that much fun
you can't be 45 or 46 and trying to join
us you know peaking in the Zeta house
windows you know we're running in there
in the middle of the night and hiding a
couple pairs of panties in your [ __ ]
mouth or throat so you got to really
enjoy it now and it sounds like you have
that opportunity man I would go I would
go you could take a year off and then go
but I would go to college cuz it's a
blast but I go to summer school and take
some action man get your [ __ ] together G
up drink a Red Bull or something or have
half a red bowling
go in there but because at a certain
point man I I'm not trying to preach you
but at a certain point some people that
don't do you know not doing anything for
yourself not getting your work done - it
starts to become a bad habit now you
might be a slow starter that late
bloomer you know you might be frickin
late bloomer Esiason boy but you got to
get out the ickey woods baby and get
into fricken you know into some greener
pastures because that's what it seems
like you know there's kind of two roads
to go usually the road where you got to
put a little more effort in the road
where you could just take it easy so I
put in a little effort get through the
summer school dude and then have some
opportunities but don't be a little ho
you feel me man get out there gang brah
um man let's take a patreon question
that came in sorry to just be going to
the questions today guys I know
sometimes this maybe looks like kind of
a crutch but this weekend I'm coming to
some shows though I will tell you this
I'm excited I'm gonna be in San Antonio
on Wednesday I'm gonna be in Austin on
Thursday Tulsa on Friday and Oklahoma
City on Saturday and all those shows
everybody all the seats I believe are
sold out there be a couple tickets may
be released but I do not know when so uh
but those are yeah I'm excited I'm
really really excited to get down there
I love going to Texas and it's going to
be a real hoot
here is a
here's a question that came in fade the
Vortech from our patreon she hit us up
do you dear family members listened to
the podcast are they supportive of you
sharing stories about your life and
family on the podcast and in your
stand-up material thank you for the
support fey and the question yeah I
think so you know they don't really
admit to it if they do my brother
sometimes will say I listen to some of
it you know he listens to it from I
think a very like on judgemental place
he told me one time he said hey man be
careful about sharin which you feel
sometimes or sharing stuff he just you
don't want to kind of corner yourself
into a weird place where you know he
said just be careful just be careful you
know you know I think uh he goes I think
you just need just you know he wasn't
saying to stop he didn't say don't he
just said be careful and I can
understand what he's saying you know
sometimes it's like you know what stuff
is is like personal to share and what
stuff isn't but my family was never
really close when when I was growing up
so it's kind of I feel like we've always
almost looked at each other as these
separate entities than we have as a
group and actually even to go back to
the co-parenting stuff you know I feel
like it in some ways I've really
struggled become because of that you
know I remember I only saw my father
kissed my mother one time and it was on
the top of her head during it was her
birthday and she was pissed off about it
kind of you know and he just they be
each been having you know they'd had a
little bit of that champagne that God
dropped some often my dad always said he
bought it but you know him and the guy
with him fight about the prices at a
champagne and [ __ ] on the porch and the
[ __ ] was free so my dad's like you're
getting you know we all notices you you
know old stale champagne so but anyway
he brought in a bottle from our mom's
birthday and then he kissed from the top
of the head and I just remember seeing
my mom just be disappointed
and and I was already such an away kid
I'm not saying that that damaged me or
changed my life or anything you know I
was already predestined to have a level
of I think awareness as a child that I
was going to be highly sensitive but you
know but to go back to just a previous
like you know we my family didn't build
up those connections I didn't really
have an understanding of relationships
you know my father slept on the couch
always I never saw him a mom I didn't
even know that they had a room together
you know I didn't even understand it so
you know I think I definitely picked up
on that energy you know I don't know if
I could ever share a room with a woman
of you know he says talk about that
sometimes I ever got a house or
something I would have to get maybe a
different room for my wife or a separate
house and that sounds crazy man but
that's just you know I don't know me and
maybe I can defeat that over time but
man it just there's something that's you
know I don't know if I was out there or
not you know I remember on Christmas I
would go out there my dad would be on
the couch all the time and it was just
kind of weird and but I don't know as a
young man as a young kid if you go out
you know I remember feeling sorry for my
dad I felt bad for him and I remember
like my mom was in this closed off space
at the other end of the house it wasn't
really closed off but there was like a
couple doors you know that usually at
night I think we're closed and so I
could I could go knock or someone but my
dad was there he was accessible he was
on the couch and so so I would you know
end up seeing him and he was kind of
awkward and uncomfortable maybe and also
older and probably asleep and smelling
like champagne and and so my mom always
felt closed off to me she felt far away
I think when I was a kid
and my dad probably felt rejected or
emasculated or let down and those
energies I think do float around in the
air they float around in the air and
then landing a child so nothing ways we
don't know in places we don't know and
they land in a child and I look I'm just
kind of guesstimating trying to just go
through my own you know my own history
like searching my browser history of my
own brain and feelings but but so we
didn't have that connection is what I'm
saying
we didn't have a lot of those
connections me my sisters you know then
I you know I my dad left and then he
passed away I went to live with friends
at 14 we never were always separate
entities so if they were to be upset
about things I think they probably
learned more about me through this and
sometimes I think the only reason I even
do this podcast is just kind of you know
in this real far-fetched circle is so
you know so maybe just so my mother will
Know Who I am a little bit or something
I don't know that might sound crazy but
so as sometimes I hope that she listens
you know but I don't know if she and I
are at the communication level where she
would ever you know she'll say sometimes
I saw some of your podcaster I saw a
clip but I don't know if she you know I
don't know I mean sometimes I feel like
I mean I've said it before that most of
my life is just a debt has been just a
desperate just just miss Elaine it just
errant and Confused attempt to try and
connect with my mother probably and not
even an attempt that I'm always
conscious of sometimes an attempt that's
just
you know just like somebody throwing
just rocks you know like a lake at night
or something and they're also are into
the ocean and I and they're also
sleepwalking so they don't even know
they're doing it you know it's
interesting when I thought really I wish
I could really had a good chart of
everything I've ever done in my life or
because I bet there's a lot of just
miscellaneous patterns that I've had
that have just been attempts to connect
[Music]
the mother or with someone with a parent
with someone or with myself even maybe
you know I'm I'm not sure but sometimes
I wonder if Oh sometimes I wonder for
all of us what we do is just some
reflection or some inverse our behaviors
are just an inverse of
if our behaviors are just an inverse of
like unsettled
emotional debts that we have with our
parents are with our childhood or with
like if everything we do is just this
kind of mummy kind of like this zombie
walk to fill these couple little things
that were never filled you know these
couple needs is a child I don't know but
that's why I mean I do think of the
parenting is very important you know
because you're just gonna give the kid
the best shot so you can't have the kid
[ __ ] uber in two hours to go meet the
other one I think that's a little tricky
there's just not ideal but then also
that's a lot of where we are these days
that's a lot of where we are but moving
forward we can do it difference so if
our parents were far away from each
other moving forward it's like well am i
able to be able to have an adult
conversation with this man or this woman
and say hey you know I know we have this
kid you know we disagree with you know
we're not in love but can we be can we
cohabitate or be in the same space or
close enough to each other where we can
have an effect on this kid's life easily
you know but just because it could be
something that's really gonna start
popping off or it could not be you know
we don't know which way the tide is
always going to go sometimes the moon
will get tricky and kind of do a
different pull on the water um what else
let's take in one more call you know and
thank you guys so much for the calls and
for helping me think about these things
and for hearing your thoughts you know I
do love the fact that uh you know it's
episodes like this that kind of remind
me not like that helped me they don't
remind me they really helped me try not
to be a know-it-all man
that's a scary thing isn't it because
that's easy that's an easy thing for me
to be and no at all not to listen not to
connect you know just to be cut off
because it's more comfortable if I know
it all then I don't have to learn
anything from you if I know in the truth
I don't know much I don't even know much
think about that think about all there
is to know and think about what you
would do when I think about all there is
to know and what I think and when I
think about what I know do um we're
gonna need to see you in the principal's
office Theo cuz I am uh I'm definitely
turning in my work late you feel me I'm
coming up a little light so ya know but
it's funny that I'll be a know-it-all
sometimes just to really prevent me from
cuz if I know it all I don't have to
listen to somebody else tell me
something I'll have to listen to your
idea I want to connect with you it's
just another way I don't have to connect
you know you can stay out of it I can
stay alone I can stay
just me you know I don't have to let
anybody in
it's it's you know it's I don't know
it's just a wild experiment that we're
in isn't it it is a wild beautiful
possibly planned experiment and this is
the gift man this is it let's hear
another call right here
homeward hey Theo this is uh you can
call me CC for now you'll understand why
I was but I okay Cece and I like names
like that CC DD Randy
Timmy Tim Tim I like some different
names blazer I used to notice fellow
named blazer I had a problem that I
thought you know the Rat King and the
Kingdom might be able to help me out
with so one of my co-workers I started
working with about three months ago he's
been there 27 years with the company
Healy talks about our boss about how we
screwed him over over some money and
some workers comp whatever I try to stay
out of it but I got some big Tony
Ferguson here so people think I'm a good
listener
you got that T Fergana Fergie forgive
you a long time booing that them you got
them freaking you get them sonar or some
them bat wings them dark sound [ __ ]
suckers homework anyway um so the other
day he showed me a one of those little
pocketed voice recorders and so I'm
worried that I'm on the CCTV looking at
this little pocket voice recorder device
and I noticed it to get stitches but I
think the students trying to blackmail
him and my boss was a good guy I know
his family so I'm wondering what should
i do should I tell tell my boss tell his
family leave like an anonymous note
whatever yeah that's pretty much it
Gang Gang I guess and peace [ __ ] up well
look man it sounds like you are right
now knowledgable of a crime
so if you're knowledgeable of a crime
then you got to tell somebody you got to
turn somebody in bucko
I mean if somebody's taking money from
your boss cause here's the thing if the
money goes away and then what the
company's gonna go away dude if the
money goes away you gonna get paid less
if the boss doesn't have his you know
suddenly his family don't have as many
Capri Suns in the cabinet they're not
going down there to Pensacola every year
to get them you know to get sunburned as
a team then if they don't have those
opportunities less money in the boss's
pocket then there's gonna be less pay to
go around for you guys so if your boy
over there is blackmailing people that's
really that's a dark heart man so I
think but then also if you just don't
know what he's doing and he's got these
crazy phone videos and [ __ ] and you
sound you know you turning it menu over
here Inspector Gadget and nobody's even
there's no malfunction then you're gonna
st. you gonna seem like a real muppet
you're gonna seem like a real [ __ ]
like a real just a just like a plastic
missile like a little real [ __ ] missile
so I if you think he's blackmailing your
boss I think you gotta say something
which one of them is more your boy
that's what I would go with you know I
don't think anybody extorting anybody
exploiting anybody I mean I'm getting
exploited by the shitty bird dogs
company you know these people you know
they they baited us too with helping out
with a video helping out their company
and then the guy is a piece of [ __ ] you
know
so that kind of stuff it's not cool to
do to people if somebody's stealing from
someone it's not right now if your boss
is a real piece of [ __ ] and he owes the
guy a bunch of money or something and I
think just trust your instincts I'm cool
with Robin hooding and if you got a
Robin Hood a little you know when I used
to do check out at the groceries I'll
tell you when the rich people would come
through I'd scan one box of cereal at
scan at 3 or 4 times they didn't notice
they had three carts they had two kids
all of the kids beautiful one of the
kids had on a sterling bracelet one time
sterling silver 40 you know 40 karats or
something you know 50 karats
I think Danny's little this kid was
[ __ ] 9 months old I'm like look at
this kid over here got dressed up like
dang you got wrist like Willie Nelson
dude had lunch a damn turquoise
beautiful turquoise hitters on his
wrists and the kid barely could hold up
a cabbage off his chest very 9 months
old and these people got that money so I
would you know I'd scan their box of
cereal three times and then when the
mother come through and she only got a
couple chives in there and she got a you
know she got a kid on one you know she
got a kid on on each chit and one of
them's kind of a little bit jaundice I
would say hey they had three boxes of
cereal I was scan it won't just scam one
my register came out even so I think you
play about I think you can do that one
yourself man I don't I mean if our
listeners have a suggestion that's fine
but as always you can hit the hotline
with anything nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and because
yeah you just got it you know what's
best man you got to trust yourself trust
your instincts if this dude is out there
scholar wagon then you got a nipple you
know you gotta [ __ ] put a nick in his
nuts put a nick in his nuts but if he's
out there Robin Hood and baby than just
Friar Tuck a little bi about you know
pick up a damn lamb leg and relax
thank you guys for for being a part of
the episode this week we've got some
really neat guess we got the the wolf of
Wall Street is coming in this week
Jordan Belfort who else we got Oh some
really groovy UFC fighters you know
rosanne is going on tour it looks like
they're announcing a tour with Andrew
Dice Clay mom called it the beginning of
the podcast I checked in with her you
know I was driving over here and my uber
driver was saying something and you know
sometimes it's easy for me to talk to my
mom sometime I'm so frustrated I just
don't want to you know I don't want to
hear her voice you know I just heard it
so much when I was a kid and it was
uncomfortable to me and I'm not mad at
her it just this is what happened and so
I don't want to hear it I don't even
like hearing if I get into a new bruh I
asked the man I said we turn off the
direction the woman say in the
directions over and over again I don't
know why any uber driver would leave
that on immediately I can't tip somebody
that leaves that voice on okay this is
some ladies just telling us where to go
for the next 22 minutes I'm out bruh
but I had him turn it off and I said man
sometimes it just it grates me that
voice he said why I said you know just
reminding I think I'm being young my mom
was always on me and it just graded me
man it just was too much there was
nothing to balance it out you know my
there wasn't that the the other softer
voice of a father sometimes and or my
mother couldn't be a soft voice that she
wanted to be because she had four
children and there was no man to help
you know she's your mama that even and
maybe have a chance to be a you know a
real sweet mother
ah but it you know it's and he goes well
you know you just have to love your
mother and he just reminded me and he
goes you just call her you text her you
know
no one else has that experience with you
where they carry you in your they carry
them in your body I mean what if a
sandwich that you ate you know showed up
nine months later and told you you know
it was your son and it looked a little
bit more like you would if you had a you
know you had a Reuben her you had a BLT
and that [ __ ] showed up nine months
later and said it was your child you'd
be like damn what you were in my body
but I didn't know it was like that and
they're like it is like that it is like
that Papa you know I'm your chimichanga
I'm you're our son let's do notice to uh
a student um
but can you l you know my Spanish is
kind of bad or or this you know the
connection is bad here but sometimes you
know we find our family where we can you
know we find our family where we can and
I'm happy to have I'm just happy to just
be here today with you guys man this is
honestly my week I'm really I had a good
weekend I met some new friends I
actually had some neat experiences but
but this has been the best part of it by
far you guys be good to yourselves and
I'm playmaking it on the way and we
played Alabama by Bishop gun and on the
way out
I'm gonna play making it Bob Bishop gone
I'm just staying on that BG they're
gonna be opening up for the Rolling
Stones can you believe that that little
band they're open enough the Rolling
Stones in Houston Texas here we go you
guys be good to yourselves may he
deserve
I ain't seen home is about a hundred
days I can almost hear momma bleep for
my restless soul and now he made a
dollar night spell but where it's going
Inc you me and I still get where I'm
bound go
wrong
[Music]
most all of my plans slip right through
my hands my god match to me
[Music]
if they'll spiral wasn't our glance ups
Nathan I'm about an hour yeah
Oh
but how
I'll bet
[Music]
making good
but I'm importing a stream for the shape
[Music]
[Applause]
I hate seen old men powerful to date I
can almost hear mama peel our recipes
[Music]
Oh